- What I do in my book
is rather than say,
okay, all of these
things that people
have been canceled for
joking about you can,
I take it 9 million
steps further.
And I say, there's no such thing
as something that
you can't joke about.
And yes, I'm including religion.
Yes, I'm including death.
Yes, I'm including
terminal illness
because there's research
that backs this stuff up.
I'm not just saying this.
(suspenseful music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the co-host of
the number one show
in late night, "Gutfeld!"
with an exclamation point
as well as author
of the new book.
"You Can't Joke About That:
Why Everything Is Funny
Nothing Is Sacred."
And we're all in this
together, my friend Kat Timpf.
Welcome finally, is this
your first appearance?
This is it, first time
on "The Rubin Report?"
- It is.
It is actually.
It's been a long
time coming, but yes,
this is my very first time.
I'm very excited to be here.
- Very first time.
Now, first off, technically
am I, is that correct?
Are you a co-host on "Gutfeld"?
I mean, you're in the
chair basically every day
and Tyrus is in the other chair
and then there are
two other guests.
But are you technically,
did I get that right?
- Yeah, no, that's right.
Greg will call me that,
so I think it's allowed.
- I told you right
before we started
that I'm gonna treat
you like Greg treats you
because I want you
to feel at home here.
Is that, is that
all right with you?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Okay, very good.
Let's get, well,
before we get into
some of the politics stuff
and the stuff around free speech
and all the stuff that we're
normally talking about,
you go a bit into
growing up and youth
and how that sort of frames
some of the beliefs
that you have.
So you wanna do a little
bit of that first?
- Are you talking
about, you know,
when I started doing
standup back in,
you know, when I was growing
up, when I was 22, that's-
- I was even going
back further than that,
growing up in a
Catholic household
and some of the sacred cows
there, but we can do that too.
- Oh, okay.
Yeah, I mean it's like,
that's the first chapter
and then the Catholic household
is the second chapter.
I can get into either one.
So for me, I mean this is
the final chapter in my book,
but for me, comedy
is a religion for me
because I unfortunately
don't have a religion.
I say unfortunately because
I think I probably would be,
I know I would be happier
if I were religious,
but I just, I can't
really seem to get there.
I hope that it changes
someday for me.
But comedy actually does
a lot of the same things
as religion does, right?
It brings people
closer together.
It can add meaning to certain
experiences in your life,
including the traumatic ones.
It can, you know,
be healing mentally.
It can be healing emotionally
and even physically.
The boost that you
get from laughter
and your immunity and there's
all these different studies,
the two things that
it's really missing is,
first of all, there's no
promise of eternal life
with any joke, no matter how
good it is, unfortunately.
And the second thing that's
missing is forgiveness, right?
Because every religion has some
sort of path to forgiveness.
The Catholic church
was confession,
which I would go and
always be honest,
even when it was I was
old enough where my sins
were a little bit
less comfortable
to talk to an older
strange man about.
But you learn, you
read the Bible, right?
Leviticus is Old Testament.
So it's like not,
it's not chill,
it's like, and the New
Testament comes in,
is like supposed to
be about forgiveness
and chill and all, you
know, more easy going.
Leviticus is extremely
fire and brimstone text.
But even Leviticus, the
standard is eye for an eye,
what we're doing right
now with comedy and speech
is actually stricter
and more fire and
brimstone than Leviticus
because I don't think
anybody would tell,
would be able to
honestly tell you
the worst thing that
they've ever been through
is hearing a joke that
they thought was offensive.
But there's-
- If you watch Jimmy Kimmel,
it can be quite grueling.
- Well see, but there's
more than one person
who would say telling
the wrong joke
actually is the worst thing
that they've been through
because they maybe
lost everything
or lost millions and
millions of dollars
or lost their
respect or, you know,
ability to come and be a
human in the square, right?
The public square.
So I feel like if the way
that we are treating jokes
is stricter than Leviticus,
we're doing something wrong.
- What year did you
start doing standup?
- So I started
doing it in college.
I did it a few times, so I
graduated college in 2010.
And then after that,
when I left college,
I moved to LA, it was supposed
to be a short-term move
and then I was going to, I
was gonna, I had a fellowship,
a stipend to live out there.
I had an internship at Fox News
and then I had gotten into
Columbia Journalism School.
So I was gonna use my stipend
for housing until it ran out
and then live with my college
boyfriend for two weeks.
And then we were gonna break
up and then I was gonna go
to Columbia and it
didn't work out that way.
It was a very, I'm 21,
so it's a very dumb plan,
but where I wasn't dumb was
taking out an $80,000 loan
for journalism school.
So I decided instead
to just stay in LA,
get journalism internships
and learn skills for
free and wait tables.
But things got really
rough for a while.
The boyfriend broke up with me.
I had to move into this really,
I was living in squalor.
I mean, I got fleas and
scabies the same week.
My cat got the fleas,
I got the scabies,
but then the fleas
jumped onto me.
That was the same week
I lost my apartment.
I was running myself ragged.
I write up all about
it in my first chapter.
But what I was doing that
made me feel power in my life
was standup comedy.
Every free moment I had,
I was going to open
mics anywhere I could
and talking about my
dumpster fire life on stage
and making jokes
about these things
that were making me
feel so helpless,
gave me some power over it
and hearing people
laugh and all of that.
And it just makes me kind of
nervous and terrified and upset
about what we're seeing
happen in our culture
where you can't joke
about sad or serious
or controversial
subjects when really,
that's the way that
I've found healing
through every tough time
in my life was by joking
about the stuff you're not
supposed to joke about.
- Do you look back on them?
I think I already
know the answer
and think of those
years, the scabies years
as the good old days
because I know for me,
for those 10 years of
struggling in New York City
as a standup and standing out
in Times Square with tickets
and literally being
broke to the point
that I had a friend who would,
who worked in food service
and would deliver me
industrial sized cans of tuna
that I would eat for weeks
and all of that stuff, I now
look back at them kind of like,
oh those were the good old days.
Like, I have everything I
want now, my life is good,
but like there's something
charming about that struggle
once you make it to the
other side, I guess.
- Right, exactly.
It actually is really
strange just how,
like in what a specific way I
was able to achieve my goals.
Because back when that guy
and I were still
dating in Los Angeles,
we were at his brother's
house and we used to
always watch Red Eye because
it was on at midnight there.
And I was like, I would
be so good on this show.
And his brother was like,
"You're a cashier at Boston
Market", which was true.
If you think in terms of
what's likely to be possible,
I shouldn't have even
gotten on the show,
let alone been the
co-host of the show
that would follow that up.
But it is remarkable.
But man, those times
were absolutely rough.
I mean the treatment
for scabies,
I dunno if you've ever had it.
You have to cover your
entire body in a cream
and just sit there
for like hours on end.
And the fact that that was
the same time I had to move
in with this Colombian
family of this bartender
that I was sort of seeing at
my California pizza kitchen job
and all these
conversations about how
just 'cause I need to
live here doesn't mean
we're together, together,
just sitting there at
his house, his mom's ...
My Spanish was never better.
Which is I think is like
the one positive thing
of that experience.
I was very good at
Spanish back then,
but you know, like,
I don't know how
I would've gotten through it
if I wasn't able to laugh at it
because if you
laugh at something
then you're telling yourself,
oh, it's not that scary.
Or you're telling that
thing, you're not that scary.
And that's the only way I
was able to get through it.
And now, I'm just
worried that that's
not gonna be possible
for many people anymore.
People are too afraid.
- Wait, I wanna keep
going with that.
But you worked at Boston Market
and California Pizza Kitchen.
Any other major
chains on your resume?
- Ruby Tuesday.
Oh, and Ruby Tuesday, with
the salad bar and everything.
- Yes. I also worked at a diner
called Four'n Twenty
Diners at Sherman Oaks.
It was a pie place.
It was supposed to be
four and twenty blackbirds
baked in a pie.
But of course everybody,
a lot of people would
think it was a restaurant
that just made edibles.
So I would have to
explain to people
like, no, there's no
weed in our food, sorry.
- I used to live
in Sherman Oaks,
I don't remember the pie place,
but that might have been the
edibles. I'm not so sure.
Does this all like, seem
very obvious to you in a way?
Like, you know, obviously
on the show you guys
are talking about the
woke thing constantly
and it just has infected
everything, everyone gets it.
But when you see just
all of these hysterical,
joyless kids who are so
confused about reality
and have no sense of humor
and have gone out of their way
to cancel everybody from
the past and, you know,
go after every show
that we used to love
or that "Friends" now, you
know, Jennifer Aniston says,
"Friends" they could
never put on air,
for the record, I'm more
of a "Seinfeld" guy.
But it just seems like
the obvious extension
of this hysteria, doesn't it?
- Yes, and see what
I do in my book
is rather than say,
okay, all of these things
that people have been canceled
for joking about you can,
I take it 9 million
steps further.
And I say, there's
not such thing
as something that
you can't joke about.
And yes, I'm including religion.
Yes, I'm including death.
Yes, I'm including
terminal illness
because there's research
that backs this stuff up.
I'm not just saying this,
I mean, I write a chapter
obviously about the shitbag,
which I had that
emergency surgery,
I had an ostomy for five weeks.
And as I was being
wheeled into my surgery,
I was like, what am
I gonna tell people?
Because I know that
everybody's gonna be like,
oh, like so weird
around me about it
or scared about what to say.
Same way as when my
mom died at a young age
and the friends I
wanted to talk to
weren't the ones with the
most carefully chosen words,
they were the friends
who just were able
to joke around with me about it.
I joke around about, I threw
a cats out of the bag party
after where I had some unused
but already open ostomy bags.
We were bonging
champagne out of 'em.
And then I started
thinking more,
'cause I had a lot of time
to do nothing but think
because I had some, you know,
the ostomy and it was
also the pandemic.
But think about all the people
who have died
recently of cancers
we didn't know that they had.
Like Chadwick Boseman,
like Norm McDonald,
because they didn't wanna
be treated differently.
They didn't want the illness
to be the defining thing
that people thought about
when you talked to them.
And you actually, I mean I
cite this research in my book.
There's people that
are terminally ill,
people that are, they
treat the terminally ill
who rank humor as being
super high on their list.
Even in one study
that was pretty small
but still higher than
the management of
their physical pain.
When I wrote the chapter,
I Googled searched cancer
and then how to tell
people I have cancer.
And the second one
had way more results.
So clearly everybody
kind of gets this,
but people are
too afraid because
of what the
consequences might be
if they say the wrong thing.
But actually what
you're really doing is,
the people you're hurting
the most are the ones
who the rules are supposed
to be in place to protect.
- Do you sense that's
changing a little bit.
I mean, even if you
were just looking
at the success of "Gutfeld!"
I mean, it is by far the
number one show in late night,
which as you know,
on the debut episode,
I predicted that he
would be number one.
I said it was gonna take a year,
it took him only about
four months or something,
which is incredible.
But I mean, the fact is the
one politically incorrect show
on late night is the number
one show in late night.
So that shows you that
something's shifting at least.
Or maybe it's just exclusive to,
you know, kind of our
side of the aisle.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Especially because there's
so much to joke about
when it comes to, you know,
the current administration
and I think a lot of
other shows are kind of,
they don't wanna do that.
I mean, our show, you
can kind of say stuff
that you can definitely not
say on other, on other shows.
It's a very comfortable place.
And even for somebody like me,
where I'm not a Republican,
I'm Libertarian very much so,
and everybody who watches
the show knows that,
I don't fit into
a particular box.
And I feel very comfortable
on that show expressing myself
even when I do have
opinions that might differ
with the, you know, typical
conservative audience.
And it's just,
everything's cool.
And I just think that
when we talk about speech
and we talk about comedy,
a lot of the argument is,
okay, I can say whatever I want
and you can't stop me no matter
how divisive it might be.
And that's true, but that
also I think really ignores
the way that comedy
and open communication
can bring us all together
because we're never gonna be
able to understand each other
if we can't fully express
ourselves to each other.
- Yeah, it's true.
Do you remember when you first
wanted to make people laugh?
I mean, I remember the
exact moment, 1983,
I was sitting in my
parents' living room
watching Bill Cosby himself.
And this was way
before, you know,
serial rapist Bill Cosby,
or at least that we knew of.
And I remember thinking,
this is, you know,
the chocolate cake thing.
And I was just like,
this is the funniest
thing I've ever seen.
That's what I, how could
you not wanna do that?
- Yeah, I mean, I've
always been a performer,
but I have an atrocious
singing voice.
But I, like, I
try to get lessons
and the woman called
my mother and said,
"I don't feel right about
taking your money anymore.
She's never gonna get it."
But I would still audition
for all the musicals
at the community theater and
I would just get on stage
and I would sing Happy Birthday.
Everyone had, you know, vocal
coach and all this stuff,
and they had these
prepared numbers
and I'd look at them
like, I'm a star, baby.
Like, I don't know
what you're thinking.
Like, put me on the show.
And I would always
have these small roles
because I actually
really truly can't sing.
So I got more into
comedy and you know,
it's also something that I
was bullied a lot as a child
and if I could laugh at it,
it became so much easier.
I mean, even to this day,
I write a whole chapter
about toxic positivity
where there's this
idea now that if,
you know, if you don't like
something about your body
or your face or something
like that, just love it.
Instead of not liking it,
just love it and then
you'll be super happy.
And I don't doubt that
that would be true,
but what if you can't?
I don't think it's
possible for anybody
to be completely optimistic
about themselves all the time.
And studies back that up too.
I mean, this idea
of body positivity
has been around forever,
but it's actually,
nobody's actually
capable of doing it.
And what I found as
a great replacement
is to make fun of the things
that I hate about myself.
So if somebody says something
to me about something,
you know, like I
have a flat chest.
Like, oh, I was already
at brunch joking
about how my bra size
is double mastectomy.
Like I've already, I beat you
and I've made these
things less scary
by finding them,
you know, funny.
- You know, speaking
of health stuff,
we actually have
something in common
that I did not know till
you told me privately.
I'm actually not sure if you've
talked about it
that much publicly,
but my audience knows about
seven years ago or so,
when I first started
getting popular
and I was getting all this hate
and I didn't realize I wasn't
dealing with stress well.
I developed alopecia
and I lost probably
40% of my hair.
Huge chunks all over my head.
I went on crazy
experimental medications.
It was by far the most
depressed I've ever been.
I almost quit.
Like, I actually had a
night where I was like,
I'm not gonna be on
camera anymore, I'm done.
I'll just go do something else.
But you got that too,
not not too long ago,
but I have to say,
your hair's looking
quite luxurious at the moment.
- So I have extensions in,
but my natural hair is
even like down to here now.
- Nice. Nice.
- And at my, you
know, mid twenties
I lost about a similar amount.
It was so thin, it was really
patchy and only to here
and it was like,
see-through, it was very bad.
I wouldn't wear it down
ever without extensions in,
I mean, I would wear
like hats a lot.
I'd put my hair
up in a messy bun,
I'd try to like cover
the parts of my skin.
It was really, really bad.
Which is why actually I felt,
I never felt more
relevant than when
Will Smith hit Chris Rock,
because I am a
woman with alopecia.
I have done standup and
I get how painful it is,
but also you can't hit somebody.
- Right.
- And I wasn't
surprised to see that
because of the whole
words are violence thing.
Because if words are violence
then violence is an acceptable
response to violence.
And I will never understand
how this is being seen
as a progressive value
because it's actually
only as we become more
modern and civilized
as human beings
that we say, okay,
only words to respond to words.
I mean, you think about it,
for most of human history,
even, you know, civil war,
like you said something
bad about my mom,
now we're gonna have a
shootout in the yard.
That's what we used to do.
So I don't know why
these people are like,
words are violence
and I'm a progressive.
It's like, no, you're
behaving like a Neanderthal.
And I think there's such
a difference between
expressing something that
maybe hurt your feelings
because you wanna share
that or you wanna share
that you were hurt and
trying to use hurt feelings
to place yourself in a
power position over others.
And the latter is definitely
what words are
violence is all about.
Because as soon as
you've said that
what that other person
did was violent,
the fact that you're just
keeping it at verbal only
is you doing them a favor.
- Right, and they don't
think violence is violence
because they'll tell
you words are violence,
but then they'll
tell you burning down
a Pep Boys is nonviolence.
Well, ask the guy who's in
the bathroom at Pep Boys.
Let me ask you this 'cause
you said you're a libertarian
and you're obviously on Fox,
which is mostly conservative.
And I always tell my audience,
conservative is a very
wide thing right now,
if a gay married guy with
two kids whose pro-choice
can be thought of as a
conservative, then okay, fine.
That thing's pretty wide.
But is it weird to
you as like, you know,
a relatively young
chick in New York City
that the progressives are
the miserable ones also,
like you, I know you
don't really care
about someone's
sexual preference
or what they wear
or what they smoke.
Obviously that's all
the libertarian stuff,
but that used to jive
with the progressives
where I'm guessing
when you do a show now
it's all conservatives
who maybe want
a little more
government than you do,
or maybe certainly
on the religion side,
but those are the
ones that support you.
- Yeah, it's very,
very interesting
because I'm never
gonna fit in anywhere
just because of, you
know, I just don't,
and I always vote third
party, I always have.
I am, you know, and
I'm not gonna lie,
I mean, I'll say things on
Fox that are more libertarian,
I'm more liberal on,
you know, social issues.
I'm very live and let
live, for example,
and they'll say something to me,
but then there is
people on the left
who won't listen
to me say anything
and they'll just say, oh,
she works at Fox News,
I know everything I
need to know about her
and she's disgusting.
And like I even
had to, you know,
cut off contact with a
one of my closest friends
who I knew since
I was a teenager
because after Trump
became president,
my views never changed.
I'd already actually
been working here.
But the fact that I, for
example, had Joe Jorgenson,
the libertarian
candidate for president
on my comedy advice
show, "Sincerely Kat"
was a huge issue for him.
He was like, you
know, you're not,
is is this really good
to be doing right now?
Is this, and then they
bring words like safety
and this and that into it.
And it's like, what
if I work at Fox News,
but I'm also my own
person with my own values
and I'll have any
conversation you want.
I'm not scared.
I think conversation's good.
I mean, that's my
whole thing, right?
But to just say,
I know who you are
because of where you work.
And it's like, don't
you work at a bank
like some of these people?
(Rubin laughing)
- At Fox News, there
actually are people
who aren't, it's not
all Republicans here,
obviously, it's right leaning,
right, everybody knows that.
But you don't know everything
that there is to know about
me just from where I work.
So I think it's the
people on the right,
they might be like,
oh, I don't like that,
you know, I disagree
with you or whatever.
But they will at
least acknowledge me
as an individual
with different views,
where as people all on the
left will often be like,
you work there, therefore I
don't wanna associate with you.
- How shocking has
that been to you?
Because obviously, I
mean, I feel the same way.
If you would've told
me of 10 years ago,
Dave, you're gonna be on
Fox basically every day
and you're gonna be friends
with all of these
crazy right-wingers,
I would've been like, what
are you talking about?
But I find them open
and fun and decent
and that's why I
don't have a problem
when people say
I'm a conservative
because it's like, well,
conservative basically just
means kind of roughly sane.
I'm with you probably on
all the libertarian stuff,
but it's just kind of yeah,
you believe in reality.
How about that?
- Yeah, it's been shocking.
I mean, I'm hoping
that this book can be
something that brings
people together
because I really do
believe that we all agree
on a lot more of this stuff
than people want to admit
for whatever reason.
But it's definitely
been shocking to me,
especially when it's been
people in my personal life
who have known me
for all these years
and they acknowledge that
my views haven't changed.
I haven't changed as a person.
I believe the same things
that I've always believed.
I've never said anything
other than what I believe,
but it's just the fact
that I work at Fox
and I think that, I'm
all about the individual,
the autonomy of an individual
to make their own decisions.
But I also just think
that individuals,
there's so many different
kinds of people out there
and everybody's a
unique individual.
And I think that a lot
of our problems come from
not speaking with
people with whom,
not just we disagree,
but that we think we
might disagree with,
which we might not
even disagree the way
that we think we do if we
just expressed ourselves more.
- Yeah, I can tell
you from where I sit,
it's just getting harder to do
because they won't talk to us.
I mean, I think it's
what you're saying about,
okay, you're
affiliated with Fox,
so a certain amount
of people think this.
And then, you know, I just
went to DC a couple weeks ago,
every Republican
we reached out to,
16 said yes, zero Democrats.
And it's like, that's a
tough bridge to divide.
But that's a little
bit of the inmates
running the asylum
over there, right?
Like they're afraid
of their own people,
even if they would be
willing to sit down
with a scary
interviewer like me.
- Yeah, and I do have
friends in my life
that are definitely left wing,
some democrats, I honestly
can have a better conversation
with someone who's super,
super, super progressive
because at least
they see a lot of
the same flaws in
the system as I do.
They have the exact opposite
solution for which mine,
you know, they just
want the government.
I want no government.
They want all government, so-
- They hate the government.
Government should be bigger.
- Yeah, exactly.
So they see the problems,
but it's the fact
that the government,
but I can at least have
a more open conversation.
But those are people obviously
that I've known a long time
and they know me first before
they kind of know where I work.
But yeah, it's been
difficult trying to,
people will think that, you
know, if they haven't met me,
that they'll see where I work
and they're like, oh, okay,
well I know who this is,
I already know who this is
because of where she works.
And it's like, that's
actually not true.
If you just spend
five minutes with me,
you'd realize that
that isn't the case,
but you won't spend
five minutes with me
and then maybe you'll say,
it's horrible how
nobody gets along.
It's like, well, come on.
Like, I'm actually,
I'm actually trying,
I'm always open to a
conversation with anyone.
- Let me ask you a couple things
about the Gutfeld exclamation
point program over there.
I'm pretty sure the
Tyrus wants to kill me.
What's going on over there?
- No, I don't think so.
- I think that guy hates me
and he's always looking at me
like he's about to
get up and step on me.
Can you give me any insight?
- I don't think so.
- You don't think so?
- No, I don't, I don't think so.
I think you said something
about his pant leg
and then he called
you out for it.
But I mean, he's not like
he already told you that.
You know what I mean?
He's always gonna let
you know how he feels.
- We did also get into a very
drunken fight a
couple years ago.
Were you there at
that, at the hotel bar?
Greg was there, a lot of wine
and something about race
and it got very heated?
Were you-
- No, I wasn't.
- We'll take that one offline.
Okay, scratch that.
So one of the things
that I always tell people
when I come back
from doing "Gutfeld!"
and it's just always
great every time,
it's like light and fun
and like it's just a joy to do,
is that it's such a
slim staff over there.
It's like, I feel
like five people maybe
including the, the janitor
are working on that show
and how that is in such contrast
to the other late night shows
that have these massive
staffs and everything else.
But that's really how it
is right there, right?
Like you guys get in
there in the morning.
Do you help him with
the writing at all?
- Yeah.
Yes, I do.
I nobody on the staff
has just one job.
I mean, I write for the show,
I'm on the show every day.
Same with like, you
know, Greg's assistant,
but she also is like
doing production
and there's nobody on the
show who has just one job.
Our entire staff is smaller
than just the writing staff
of a Stephen Colbert
or somebody like that.
I think we have two, three
maybe people who just write,
but also they sometimes
are on the panel.
So I, that's actually
not even true.
I've been obviously, you know,
I write usually a
segment every single day
and submit the guest intros,
which is also funny
because a lot of the ones
that he's gotten yelled at
for being too mean, to me,
I wrote them so they're
like, "Don't be mean to Kat."
I'm like, am I too mean to
Kat because I wrote that?ú
- Do you ever feel like you're
gonna get him in trouble
as you're writing something
and you're like, uh-oh?
- Yeah, I have, I have.
But it's again, I
think a lot of it is,
I mean, I think it's
because I'm a woman too.
I don't think anybody
would be like,
oh you're too mean
to kill me, right?
I think it's just
because I'm a woman.
But I think that's what
I think is so great,
is I'm treated as an equal.
I mean, it's not like
I can't handle it
just because I'm a woman.
I can handle it and I
can give it right back.
And I have been for,
I don't know what,
nine years now almost.
So, I love it.
I think it's, it's the best.
I think being in
that environment
where it goes back
to intention, right?
And I write a chapter
about this too.
What matters is the intention.
And there's this very harmful
idea out there right now
that it's not the intention.
It doesn't matter if
someone's offended,
that's all that matters.
But how can that be true?
Like how can that be true
that it's exactly the same
if somebody makes a
joke unintentionally,
somebody gets
offended by the joke,
than if somebody
was purposely trying
to say something
racist or sexist
and hurt somebody, somebody,
of course that matters.
Of course that
makes a difference.
And it's just absurd
that, you know,
when it comes to like
if you kill someone
on accident versus purposely,
there's different designations
for that in our criminal code,
jokes are a little
less consequential
than someone's life.
So why are we
treating it like this?
I don't think anyone can
actually feel that way.
Of course it matters.
I mean, when I was
losing my hair,
I made jokes about
it all the time.
I mean, Greg even made a joke
that I looked like Tanner
from "Bad News Bears"
without my extensions
in, I laughed.
I thought that was great.
It was funny,
I had an ex-boyfriend
who was abusive
and would tell me
like, you know,
"Fuck you, you
rapidly aging idiot."
Like how those things
are, they're different.
Someone was trying to make
me feel bad about myself
so he could continue to
maintain control over me.
How is that not
different than somebody
who is just trying
to make me laugh?
Of course it is.
And it's just insane.
I mean all the jokes, the
times that I've gotten,
I mean I've been involved
in a few different scandals,
one with Kimmel over jokes,
that was by accident.
I was talking about
something else
and I accidentally said
something offensive
and I didn't mean
to be offensive,
but I was treated as
if I did it on purpose.
And not only is that not fair
to people making the joke,
that really doesn't reserve
the absolute shaming
that we should be
doing of people
who are trying to
be jerks on purpose.
- Right, well also with
a guy like Jimmy Kimmel
who's been in blackface
multiple times and you know,
making fun of the "black
accent" from Carl Malone.
It's like that's why he's
going after someone like you
for a joke because
he has to, you know,
bow to them forever, otherwise
they'll take him out.
- Well, I sent him a book,
probably the most embarrassing
thing that happened to me
on air was when I made a joke
about how hard it
is to give my cat
a feral cat medication
versus a human.
And it was during a segment
about how, what his hiatus was,
but we were actually also live
and I think this is the last
time we were live actually.
'Cause I was talking about
how it's super difficult
and like the cat can
claw you or whatever.
And then Greg was like,
"Oh Kat, Jimmy Kimmel's son
has like a heart issue."
And I like didn't realize that.
First of all, I get the
Fallon and Kimmel confused
and I'm now, I was like,
oh wait, I do remember.
But I remember in the
article it was like
my whole family's healthy.
I remember before I made
the joke it was like,
just so I'm not gonna get in,
I was like, I'm not
gonna get in trouble.
But also so much of comedy
is like swinging and missing.
You know, you don't really know
if something's gonna
land until you try it.
And I was just doing
that and you can't make
people too afraid to try
or else we're gonna miss out
on some really great jokes.
Not just in terms of laughter,
but some of the darker subjects
that can have those
healing powers.
But I apologized because
I genuinely did feel bad.
I was like, I didn't
mean it like that.
I don't want anybody to,
you know, think I did.
Everyone who watched the show
was actually telling
me like, you were fine.
Like, because I was holding
back tears the entire time.
I felt so awful.
The next day somebody posted
a little tiny clip
of it on Twitter
and said that I had
been making fun of him,
his family because his
son had a heart problem
and that it was harder to have
a cat with a heart problem
than a child with
a heart problem
and different,
like media outlets,
like Raw Story if
you can call it that,
took it and ran with it.
So I was ironically
at the vet with my cat
and I was like my ...
Blowing up on social media,
people telling me
like, "Fuck you",
Jimmy Kimmel's sister told
me to fuck off and die.
All of this stuff.
And like if I had actually
said, it's actually no big deal,
"fuck your kid with
a heart problem
because he has a heart problem",
I would've deserved that.
But I was trying to make
a funny joke about that
and also about people
who don't have children like me,
sometimes like having a child
can be a catch-all excuse
for everything and if
you don't have kid,
like something that's
relatable to cat owners,
something that's
relatable to people
that don't have children.
That's what I was trying to do.
And I don't think I should
be treated the same way
as if I was trying to do that.
Which is a totally, I mean
that's just abhorrent, right?
But it's, that
wasn't my intention.
And again, if we make
people too afraid to try,
then we're gonna lose
out on so much healing
within ourselves and
also with one another
through shared experiences.
- I often quote Oscar Wilde
or at least loosely quote him.
I mean, if you wanna
tell people the truth,
you better be funny or they're
gonna punch you in the face.
So it's something like that.
Let me ask you a
couple other things,
just kind of world related stuff
as people can see out
your window there.
I think you're at
the Fox News offices.
- Yeah.
- You are in midtown,
New York City.
A city that I once lived in
and loved for 20
years of my life.
But every time I go back there,
which is pretty much only to
do "Gutfeld!" at this point,
I find it to be a
zombie of a city.
It's not the same New York
Midtown where you are.
There's no business
people anymore.
Everyone kind of wearing a hood,
looks like they're going
to get weed or sell weed
or steal weed or something.
Like what is going
on in New York?
- See, I wouldn't even
mind it being seedy
if it was less expensive.
(Rubin laughing)
- A lot of things that made
New York so special too,
like the little
small businesses,
immigrant owned restaurants,
those, you know,
special little gems,
a lot of them are gone
because they couldn't survive
being illegal in the pandemic
and everything is so expensive.
I mean it's, it's so crazy.
I mean I've been thinking
about maybe having
one of those baby things
myself with my husband,
but we're like, where
would we put it?
- You know, we have no taxes,
we have no taxes on baby
related stuff here in Florida.
Florida, I say it to you
every time I see you, Florida.
- I'm just, I know and I
would, it's just this job.
I am like less concerned with
being mugged on the street
than I am knowing for
a fact I'm being gonna,
you know, I am being
mugged by the government.
They take so much of my income
and I walk outside and I'm
like, what is this for?
Where did you,
you stole my money
and then what did
you spend it on?
And it's so expensive to live
here, it's just ridiculous.
- I mean, do you
find anyone there
that thinks that
it's going well?
I mean, I still, I know a few
remaining people in New York
and everyone, I kid you not,
I think literally
everyone right now
is in the process of leaving.
And I already know
probably 20 people
that left in the
last three years.
- We would, I mean, my
husband's from New York.
My life dream was always
to live in New York.
I mean, at this point it's just,
I mean I'm also, you know, I'm,
I've grown up a little bit.
I'm, you know, married,
I'm not really going out a lot
and I'm just sit, you
know, I'm at working a lot,
so I'm at home a
lot and it's just
like my home's not that big.
When I say home, I
mean handful of rooms
that I'm paying
so much money for
that I don't even
own, I'm just renting.
And I, yeah, I don't know.
I mean I feel like also
a lot of this
commercial real estate,
I mean a lot of people
are working from home.
A lot of the, you
know, the government,
the state government
here, city government,
it's funded on this stuff.
And when that goes away,
I mean you pointed it out
too, all the for lease signs.
A lot of people aren't like,
I wanna take on this
really expensive lease
in this place that's sort of
look like it's collapsing.
So I think it's gonna
get worse actually.
- Yeah, you know, it's funny,
you must know Douglas Murray
who's a Fox News contributor.
- Yes.
- So last time I did "Gutfeld!"
and I saw you at the show,
I went out to dinner
with Douglas after,
and he's in from London now,
living in New York City.
And he kept telling me
how magical it was there
and I kept thinking,
man, if you only knew
what it used to be like,
but you are seeing the
vestiges of magical.
But I guess that
could still be magical
if you're from somewhere else.
- Yeah, I love Douglas Murray.
We sat next to each other
at the White House
Correspondents dinner.
- He is a, he is a good one.
What else is on your mind
politically at the moment?
I mean, obviously we
can do the woke stuff
till we're like
blue in the face,
but what about
the sort of divide
that's now happening between
the red and the blue?
I assume as a
libertarian you're cool
with this resurgence
of federalism.
- Right, I mean okay,
as I mentioned before,
talking about feelings I think
is actually a good thing.
I know that a lot of the refrain
when it comes to
people on the right,
I mean you included,
is that, you know,
facts don't care
about your feelings.
And I totally get that.
But it's also true
that sometimes
feelings don't care
about your facts.
And I know that it's
the only explanation
for every relationship
I had in my twenties
where I was like, but
I, but I love him.
They're like, he
treats you horrible,
he has no job, he's mean to
you, he's cheating on you.
I was like, but I love him.
So like humans are
emotional creatures.
We are gonna have emotions.
And as someone who's
pro-free speech,
I think that includes
speech about feelings.
So I think that that's something
that the right should
acknowledge more and again,
bring up that
distinction between
why you're sharing
your feelings.
There's a difference between
sharing your feelings
to try to express
yourself to another person
or hey man, that hurt me,
or hey man, have you
ever seen it this way
and let's have a
conversation and you hurt me
and now I have power over you.
And anything you say against
me, if you argue with me,
that's just further proof
that you're a sexist
or a racist or a homophobe
or a transphobe or whatever.
And those two things,
I think that what we're really
missing is communication.
And I think the more
we're open to that,
the more we can all get along
and the more speech the better
in terms of bringing
us together.
I think a lot of the issues are,
are a lot of the people who say
that they're sensitive
and tolerant,
they're really not
because they kind of wanna
catch somebody
saying something bad
because there's nothing more
powerful than being a victim.
And I hate to see that
getting lumped in with people
who do just wanna
share their feelings,
which I think is a good thing
'cause we all have them.
I'm a very sensitive,
emotional person.
But there's a
difference between that
and being somebody who
expects their feelings
to be what the rest of the
world around you caters to,
that's narcissistic,
that's selfish.
And if you act out
on other people
and try to get someone
fired, like that's bullying,
that's not being sensitive,
that's being an asshole.
And that's a very,
very important
distinction in my mind.
- To go to where we
started for a second,
you mentioned you're
not religious up top.
Is that kind of the
number one thing
that would sort of
keep you from saying
that you're a conservative?
Because I mean,
from where I'm at,
at least in the
Florida version of it,
Like it is
libertarian down here,
like nobody really cares
about weed down here.
Nobody cares who
you marry down here.
Like people have their
own personal views
and DeSantis obviously
has his own views
on abortion and whatever,
but like it's pretty
much working down here
where it is more
libertarian that is the,
the sort of freedom
version of it down here.
- See, I just want
even less government
than the Republicans do.
That's my issue.
Like I really do believe
taxation is theft.
You know, when it
comes to immigration,
I never wanted the wall.
I think that anybody
who wants to come
contribute to our,
immigration's another one.
I think that anybody who
wants to come contribute
to our economy who's non-violent
should be more than
welcome to do so.
I don't believe in the
welfare state though.
Like I don't believe in,
I think that taking,
for anybody really
and the main issue that
I used to have big,
getting into fights with
conservatives about,
which I haven't changed,
but Republicans have
is foreign policy.
I'm very non-interventionist
on foreign policy
and I've always had
the same views on it
and I used to get yelled at
from Republicans about it
and now I get yelled
at from Democrats.
(Rubin laughs)
- Right, The Tucker wing,
- I was the same the whole time.
- Right, they've moved to you
and now the Democrats are the
Republicans of 20 years ago.
- Yeah, I think I'm just very,
I can't with any of the idle
worship of any politician,
I want even smaller government
than Republicans do,
definitely than Democrats do.
I wanted to
criminalize all drugs.
I wanted to criminalize sex work
and the religious thing, I mean,
I don't think that religion
should play a role
in the government,
but yeah, I'm not religious.
That is something that
people have an issue.
I mean, people have an
issue with sometimes
who are conservative.
I don't mind it
if someone's like,
oh, I'll pray for you.
Like, that's fine.
But if people are
like, you're a jerk,
it's like, no, I'm not.
Like, I actually, I don't judge
or think religious
people are bad people.
I'm jealous, which
is, I know a sin also,
of people who are religious
because I think
I'd be way happier
if I thought that I, you know,
and I'm agnostic, I'm not an
atheist, I just don't know.
If I didn't think that
I'm just, life is,
I'm just gonna keep getting
older and older and older
until I'm like decrepit
and I'm, you know,
unattractive and you know,
then I die and it's like,
just like before I
was born, I hate that.
It's like, I don't want it
to be that way, but yeah,
I think it's a lot
of the social media.
- I think they're working on
a pill for that, don't worry.
- Yeah, in general like just,
I want smaller government
than the two party system does
and I think that the two party
system kind of sometimes,
you know, can play us
against each other a lot
and to get away with
its own corruption
because if everything's
so polarized
and you're always gonna have
your own side defending you
no matter what you do,
and that really can
just breed corruption.
- Yeah, it's interesting
'cause I'm philosophically
I'm with you on most of that.
You know, the one
though that I've shifted
a little bit probably in
the other way than you,
I think is decriminalization
of all drugs,
because I used to be for
total decriminalization,
and it's like, if you
look at San Francisco
where de facto it is, right?
Like, it's not legal
to be selling fentanyl,
but in in essence it is because
the cops don't do anything.
It's like, look at that place,
that can't be
totally disconnected
from just like an endless
drug parade. You know?
- I think actually when
it comes to drugs or--
- Or even New York
City with weed, right?
Like it, the whole
city, part of the decay,
and I hate, I'm not against
weed, 100% I'm not against weed,
but like in New York City,
the whole city smells
like weed now all the time
and everyone's stoned.
- I'm not stoned.
I think legalization--
- See, I knew we'd find one.
All right, we found
one person not stoned.
- Yeah, legalization
works into criminalization
where you can actually,
because the system
is still in place
where it's like
this loop of like,
you get into drugs and then
how you gonna make money?
You can't make money.
You know, once you have
this felony on your record
and all those sorts of things
where you could know
where you were buying,
where you could like
just get heroin,
if you wanted heroin.
If that happened tomorrow,
I still wouldn't do heroin.
Like, the reason that I don't
do heroin isn't because,
oh, it's illegal.
It's because, oh,
I'm not smoking crack
because I haven't seen that
workout well for anybody.
Even if I could buy
crack at the store.
- Except for Hunter Biden.
- I think that, I think
that your life is,
it's all your choice,
but then it's also
your responsibility,
which is the other, the
other side of that coin,
I think every, every individual
can make the decisions
for what works best
for themselves,
but then they're
also responsible
for their own consequences.
I think that it's just immoral
to take away someone's
freedom because of something
that they've decided
to put in their body.
- Kat Timpf, the book is,
"You Can't Joke About That",
I should have showed
it at the beginning,
but we got it, we
made it happen.
You know, I'm not a cable
news host over here.
You know, I'm-
- You're doing great.
- I'm doing all right.
Kat, it was good seeing ya.
I'll see you in New York.
We can wander around, catch
the wafting smoke of weed,
see if you wanna buy some
heroin, et cetera, et cetera.
- No heroin for me.
- Fine. No heroin.
Okay, see ya.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more enlightening
and maybe even
humorous conversations,
check out our comedy playlist
and if you wanna watch
full interviews on
a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notifiable
future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.